saint cyr l'école comme exemple quelques
heures seulement après la présentation
de leur projet de loi sur le logement
jacques mézard et julien de normandie
ont visité un projet de construction
emblématique en ile-de-france objectif
pédagogie et démonstrations dans ce
nouveau quartier de 25 hectares près de
4000 habitants s'installeront d'ici
quatre ans une opération qui est tout à
fait exemplaire en ce qui concerne à la
fois la mixité sociale puisque on voit
qu'il y à des efforts considérables pour
à la fois faire du logement social faire
de l'accession sociale à la propriété de
l'accession à la propriété dans un
environnement réussite pour tenter de
créer un choc de l'offre dans les zones
tendues comme en ile de france le
gouvernement souhaite notamment réduire
le nombre de recours abusifs
aujourd'hui trente mille construction
seraient bloqués à cause de ces recours
en france à saint cyr l'école le projet
de la zac achard renard a été lancé il y
a dix ans déjà
c'est un projet qui remonte à 2008 même
s'il avait été pensé avant mais le
départ c'est 2008 et ça sera pas
terminée avant 2021 2022
donc vous voyez 15 ans 14 15 ans
commence à faire beaucoup
il reste autant à construire et à livrer
qu'il a déjà été livrée avec 1500
nouveaux logements au total beaucoup
d'activités économiques
la création de 400 emplois en activité
économique les commerces et les
équipements publics
le projet de loi est lent du
gouvernement sera présenté à l'assemblée
nationale à la fin du mois de mai son
adoption devrait suivre quelques
semaines plus tard
bien avant la fin des travaux à saint
cyr l'école